you have a weight problem and it's not
just you it's everyone that's just how
life is unearthed 2.0 double the density
double the gravity double your current
weight on earth what else would change
if Earth's gravity were to double nature
infrastructure innovation evolution does
it work out prepare yourself and start
working out this is what if and here's
what would happen if Earth's gravity
were to double up the gravity on earth
by just a little bit and you ruin
everything
if Earth's gravity was just 5 percent
stronger the increase would warp our
planets near perfect circular orbit into
a tighter elliptical path summers and
winters would become a lot harsher the
intense climate change would spark
widespread famine and would likely
collapse the world economy and yet there
might be some survivors that's just from
the 5 percent difference
what happens when the Earth's gravity
doubles
let's put climate concerns aside for a
moment realistically we just wouldn't
survive a drastic change the Earth's
core would probably just collapse in on
itself causing everyone to fall to their
deaths or releasing enough heat to cook
us all alive but let's imagine that
gravity doubles at a rate that allows us
to keep our lives so we can try this new
world out well to be honest there isn't
much to look forward to you're now twice
as heavy and while that might sound like
a gift to some of you it won't be unless
you're in great shape your heart and
lungs will be strained under the
increased pressure breathing gets harder
and your blood pressure skyrockets
imagine you're basically giving yourself
a piggyback ride 24/7 sleeping gives you
bed sores stares get scary
and trips and falls might even become
fatal speaking of false powered
infrastructure our technology and nature
itself aren't equipped to handle this
type of force buckling under twice the
weight they were built for buildings and
bridges would collapse planes would fall
from the sky and satellites would tumble
back to earth since they'd no longer be
traveling at the right orbital velocity
trees would collapse under their own
weight or they would die from not being
able to pump water as high as they used
to new ones growing in their place would
be much shorter and thicker in order to
accommodate the new constraints of
double gravity and like that
perhaps humans would evolved the same
way decreased height thicker veins
increased bone density barring the
severe climate change that would occur
such as atmospheric compression and
increased radioactivity we might
actually be able to build a nice little
life for ourselves that is one where
everything is smaller and closer to the
ground but what's wrong with that anyway
double gravity or not life is short so
try something new let your mind wander
and circle back for more what if
you